[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in Peter King who joins us
before I talk football I know you uh
knew Grant Wall the great soccer writer
and uh also got an opportunity to spend
time talking to his uh his wife uh would
you like to share some of that
conversation
yeah sure Dan thank you uh yes Celine
gounder uh
who is now Grant's widow
um
I think is uh
you know when she was discussing with me
Grant's death
I think it was a cross between trying to
be clinical
and also talking about someone who she
obviously loved dearly and it was hard
at times for her I did a an interview
with her that I posted as a podcast
yesterday but the one thing that really
stood out to me is that
she feels so incredibly grateful
for everyone who has basically sung the
Praises of Grant Wall as the greatest
soccer writer and the greatest the most
influential Sports media person in the
United States about this growing Sport
and Dan back in 2010 when we both worked
for Sports Illustrated I went to cover
the World Cup in South Africa and Grant
was basically
my uh entree into this world of soccer
he took me everywhere he introduced me
to everybody he said hey go talk to Bob
Bradley the coach uh he's a big Parcels
guy you know you'll have something in
common you know he's a New Jersey guy
and so it was all that kind of stuff and
you know some people might say well geez
this is a Grant's giving you time with
people who he
um cultivated and who he wanted uh to to
to be able to work with and I always
thought that the reason he did that is
not only for total unselfishness in
class but because he wanted to see the
Game grow in the United States and so
that's why he's introducing me to
everybody he wants me to write about it
to a non-soccer crowd you know so he
just was a an unselfish guy who had so
many uh people around the country who
can say right now that he was a huge
influence in their lives and I think
that's what Celine right now really
appreciates about him yes I think that
people might know the name Grant Wall
because he did the profile on LeBron
James when LeBron was still in high
school did the cover story and the first
one to really say America here's the
future in LeBron James and then but he
really was known for being a a soccer
writer and helped grow the sport
immensely and and I hope there's some
you know posthumous honor for him that
his wife can share and his widow can
share in that's soccer related
I do too and I think U.S soccer hey look
you know you heard Becky sauerbrun Abby
Wambach uh Tyler Adams from this year's
team really uh get very very emotional
talking about Grant uh and so I'm sure
that U.S soccer is going to do something
they should do something I hope a lot of
people do something because his is a
memory that we all should cherish we're
talking to Peter King uh football
morning in America columnist comes out
every uh Monday morning and a
contributor to football night in America
NFL owners meetings the review on
roughing the passer if if I'm correct
with the numbers that they haven't
called it as often based off last year
but they've been inconsistent in how
they're calling it is that a fair way to
uh look at this topic
I think it's fair I think the issue is
that you basically because roughing the
Pastor Dan if you think about it is
almost exclusively called by the referee
there's two of these seven officials two
of the seven game officials who call the
game from the backfield one is the
Umpire and he's mostly watching uh the
offensive line and the other is the
referee and he is charged on that
specific play with watching if it's a
pass play watching the hits on the
quarterback and you have 17 people
and you have 17 even though the NFL
tries so hard to make it an absolute
equal standard it's impossible they're
human beings so you have one guy who's
going to say well that looked like he
was the quarterback was flung to the
ground and I'm gonna call it and another
referee would say hey he's just throwing
the guy to the ground he was his
momentum carried him he didn't do that
maliciously and so that's the issue
right now and look I'm all for the NFL
trying to make the game as well
officiated as possible and Dan what's
the old cliche about you know you're
never going to be perfect but if you
seek Perfection you'll be the best that
you can be that's fine but for everybody
to want to have past interference and
roughing the passer called The Same by
17 Crews it's a pipe dream it's never
going to happen
are you against replay review for
roughing the passer
I mean I'm sort of
Dan you know I think replay ought to be
used on any play that a coach wants to
challenge
and you know that's that's a
belichickism too
um but the reason that I feel that way
is that if you only have a certain
amount of challenges in a game you're
going to be judicious with them as a
coach so it's not going to be oh my God
there's going to be so many more
stoppages coaches are going to have to
save a challenge or two for late in the
game so they're not gonna throw a flag
on a on something that happens with 10
minutes left in the first quarter most
likely so all I'm saying is I'm in favor
of of being able to challenge anything
but
I mean I think there are a lot more
important things that can be challenged
honestly then hits on quarterbacks it's
it's something that is not just going to
be done in uh in a uniform way yeah I I
worry that if we start to go a little
bit closer to college you can have
automatic objections here
um you know those are review you know
they do look at those but still you're
talking about automatic objections I
don't know if the NFL gets to that point
I don't think so I can't see it I can't
see uh you know Micah Parsons five
minutes into a into a playoff game
driving uh Jalen hurts into the ground
and uh you know and Sean hockey leaves
saying ejection yeah it's just it's two
these games even regular season games
they're too important I think to make
now look it's one thing if uh if Micah
Parsons rears back and slugs Jalen hurts
in the jaw with a punch he should be
ejected but not for a football play that
maybe is over the line the NFL talked
about the lowest average score margin
for a season
there's closer games this is the lowest
average score margin for a season since
1932.
but scoring is down
how concerning do you think this is for
the NFL in the competition committee
I think it's a little bit too early to
to say we need to make such and such a
rules change about this and I know the
NFL is really really into scoring time
of game all those things
but look I think the and there I think
the NFL will say we don't want the the
scoring to go down that much but again
this is one year it's 14 weeks and and
the one thing Dan that I think that I
would say to sort of counter that that
the reason why I don't really think it's
that big a deal I think it's just you
know sort of the vagaries of a season I
don't you can't point to something and
say ha that's the reason why scoring is
down a little bit not a lot and
I would just look at some of the ratings
that the NFL has gotten this year
fans are not saying oh boy I'll tell you
what scoring is down three points a game
I'm not watching they're not saying that
so I mean you want to be cognizant of
this and you want to see if there are
things that you can do to make sure that
this doesn't become you know six points
a game eight points a game ten points a
game I get it but I think it's a little
bit early to be very reactionary about
that if we had a friendly bet as Daniel
Snyder still owning the commanders next
year
my friendly vet would say no but I have
no inside information on that Dan I just
I can't believe that the league will
continue to kowtow to Snyder and to
allow and look you can say whatever you
want about what's fair what's unfair but
if I'm one of the 32 owners in the
league and I read testimony before the
Congress of the United States that Bruce
Allen who he can be Daniel Snyder's
dread enemy right now which he is but
there was a time when they were the
closest uh you know president and and
CEO pray uh or I'm sorry owner and CEO
president whatever title Allen had they
were as close as any two uh people in
the league and so for Bruce Allen to say
that even Dan Snyder hinted at I'm going
to have Roger Goodell tailed so we can
find out some dirt on him yeah how do
you have somebody like that in your
league how do you do that and how does
Roger Goodell continually just poo
pooless like it's no big deal it's just
I just think the NFL has given Snyder
way too long a leash
but it'd be precedent and the
commissioner never wants this to get to
a vote you know it it he probably would
say to Daniel Snyder look I don't want
this to get to a vote
um you need to sell the team uh you know
Robert Sarver with the Phoenix Suns
let's not put this to a vote let's just
you you make a smart decision quote
unquote sell the team make your money
and then move on from here let's not
make this worse and this is why the
commissioner makes 60 million dollars a
year he's got to represent all of these
owners including the one that they may
want out but he still has to represent
him as well
I get it Dan I really get it I think the
biggest issue one of the biggest issues
right now is that there's so many new
owners uh and and people have come in in
the last 10 years who basically you know
like the Denver Broncos owners now uh
you know the Walton Penner uh people uh
they basically they're just sitting back
and trying to figure out what this
league is and trying to figure out the
business of football and all that and I
get that it's and that's important you
don't want to be knee-jerk in this but
at some point you have to say we just
don't want to be in business with this
guy anymore and Dan the other thing is
the NFL has spent so much time and
energy dealing with a rogue owner it it
reminds me in a little bit of a
different way of Al Davis
you know because even though Daniel
Snyder is not one of these guys who who
in a football sense is at war with the
NFL it's kind of in a business in a
business sense he is okay and I don't
even want to say at War he you know he
just he has run a once proud franchise
into the ground over the last quarter
Century there's no arguing it and and
and you know I think it's long past time
for somebody to get to a woman to say
listen for the good of your family for
the good of the game for the good of the
fans of Metro Washington you've got to
sell this team
Pete good to talk to you as always
thanks for your thoughts on Grant Wall
and safe travels thanks a lot Dan take
care Peter King football morning in
America and uh contributor to football
night in America